well we uh we support uh free and open
trade so uh we'd give this uh a welcome
but also a cautious welcome because what
we've experienced over the past few
years is that when the government has
signed trade deals uh very often once
you look at the detail uh they're not uh
quite as advantageous as the government
has first claimed but uh on the face of
it this can give us new opportunities to
trade with fast growing economies uh
around the world uh British business
British companies have great strengths
so having access to new and growing
markets could be a boost to the economy
although I do know that in the
government's own press release the Boost
that they estimate to the economy looks
pretty small over the next 10 years
well yes I'll come on to that but just
to say then if labeled were to win the
next election you would keep Britain
inside this block well I think it's
really important that when our
government signs International
agreements they don't think that our
successful government is going to tear
them all up we've had a terrible knock
to our International reputation with the
current government signing a free trade
agreement with the European Union and
then threatening to set parts of it
aside unilaterally that's not the
approach to the labor party or a labor
government would take
well on the subject of the European
Union you mentioned there that the
government's own statistics suggest that
the economic growth that would come as a
result of this deal amounts to only
about 0.08 the
the hits that the obr estimates that
brexit has caused the economy is more
like four percent do you think our
efforts should be more concentrated on
deepening economic ties with our on
their neighbors in the EU rather than
these countries that are that are
further away and we do less trade with
well I think the figures have just
quoted put the the benefits of this a
new trade agreement and to some
perspective uh compared to what we are
expected to lose over the coming uh
years as a result of the brexit decision
but the brexit decision has been taken
it doesn't mean that the uh Arrangements
that we currently have uh can never be
Revisited in any way and that's why for
example we have said we would like to
see a Veterinary agreement between the
UK and the EU to help our food and drink
exporters uh we'd like to see Mutual
recognition of professional
qualifications to help our service
Industries none of that is rerunning the
brexit argument but I do think that we
need an adult and positive relationship
with our nearest neighbors and our
biggest trading partner in the European
Union as well and by the way
the Russian Russian invasion of Ukraine
has perhaps made that more imperative
because it's put into perspective some
of the things that we've been arguing
about in recent years and what we what
we realized with these awful events
happen is that our fellow democracies
across the channel are actually much
closer to her to us and and real allies
when you see these terrible uh
aggressive geopolitical events happening
on the continent of Europe
China applied to join this block at the
same time as the UK do you have any
concerns about them being given
membership as well
our approach to China uh is one of
realism you can't wish China away it's a
really important trading partner for
businesses I'm speaking to you from here
in the West Midlands where uh the
trading relationship with China is
important but I think we've got to be
clear-eyed about it as well and some of
the rare trick that we had about uh the
Golden Era from George Osborne and David
Cameron some years ago looks a little
bit naive now so I think a clear-eyed
realistic approach to China which
maintains a trading relationship but is
also very alert on the security front uh
and on the intelligence front is the
right way to proceed
I wonder why we've got you if I can just
get your reaction to the big news that
we got late last night that um a former
U.S president Donald Trump is being
criminally indicted what is your
reaction to that news
well obviously it's part of the American
justice system to decide if there are
any charges to proceed in any any
convection to make what I would say when
I look at some of the uh rhetoric and
responses what you'll always get with
some of these politicians is then
proclaiming to be the people against the
institutions uh and it really is a
supreme conceit for any single person or
any politician to cast themselves as the
people there is no amorphous the people
there are millions of different people
with millions of different views and no
single person can try to embody the
whole populace in their own person it's
that Trend that we've seen in politics
in recent years and a deeply unhealthy
one
Shadow Chief secretary to the treasury
we appreciate your time this morning
thanks very much indeed